all right guys so it is true I've tested
positive for covid uh but I did some
research listened to a certain amount of
scientistians and I was told that if you
hit over 50 of your threes that your
actual viral load is so low it's
undetectable you could live your life as
you see fit so I'm going to take
10 threes if I hit more than five
I'm good here we go
there's one
there's two
there's three oh
there's four
there's five
there's six
incredible
it's amazing I'm feeling better by the
second
oh there's seven
is that eight oh
that's seven for nine
this is the big one
that's right
goodbye covid
where you at Steph Curry
all right people I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's December 8th 2022
and I think that's my proudest moment
that we've ever played on the show
that's right 8 out of ten threes which
according to the latest scientistians I
read it on the interwebs that means I
don't have covet anymore I don't know
that I will uh test again I think I am
going to be okay I do want to address
one thing about the covid situation so
as you know if you watch the show
yesterday if you're following me on
social media technically I do still have
covid at the moment I was in New York
and DC for a couple days a bunch of
family members have it too everybody's
going to be okay it's all good
um and I feel completely fine besides a
little bit of a frog in my throat which
seems to be going away at the moment but
a lot of people I noticed yesterday were
asking me across social media well why
did you even bother to test because
we're at this odd point in covid where
No One Believes anything related to it
at all right nobody well everyone
believes different things let's put it
that way so half the people don't
believe tests work the other half
believed that they work but maybe you're
going to get some false positives people
believe that vaccines work they don't
work get this booster if you're
vaccinated you won't get coveted if
you're vaccinated you will get covered
you'll get lesser covered like it's just
like a complete mix of anything so a lot
of people are saying Dave why did you
even bother testing if we all just stop
testing covet will go away meaning that
we just won't pay attention to it people
will get occasionally sick back in the
day you used to go to work with maybe a
little bit of a head cold or even a mild
flu or something and people would
survive
and make choices for themselves as Conor
and Phoenix did I didn't force anyone to
come to work yesterday I said you guys
make a decision they made the decision
and you guys are still alive
yeah everyone's alive in this room as
far as I can tell but anyway a lot of
people were asking why did I test in the
first place as if that was like a
concession to the uh to the covid mafia
and although I did say it yesterday as a
quick throw away I just want to
reiterate again I had it not been for us
having a four-month-old and a
two-month-old here I would not have uh
done it but because we have uh very very
young babies in the house I wanted to
take every precaution and basically I
just hung out outside all day yesterday
and I took Clyde for a bunch of walks
and I worked out actually a quite a
lovely day uh and uh hopefully by the
end of today I'll test again it'll be
fine and that'll be it but that's really
the only reason that I did that uh today
we are doing a Reuben report Community Q
a if you want to try to get a question
in last second question you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com I want to do a
couple stories up top of just sort of
like how insane celebrity culture has
gotten because there's a couple things
happening right now yeah one of them
kind of involves that Kanye guy uh but
there's just like this Focus that we've
had maybe in the last I guess we've had
it for a long time but uh let's say 20
years of just like we have to listen to
what celebrities say about things as if
that really matters as if people who
pretend often actors who pretend to do
things actors don't really do things uh
Tom Hanks was never stranded on an
island you know what I mean uh Matthew
McConaughey never went uh to the stars
in interstellar but they pretend to do
things and then we we think that it's
important to listen to them and then
it's kind of funny when you start seeing
how ridiculous uh most celebrities
actually are so we're going to talk
about some woke celebrities who are
drunk on their own Fame uh and this
includes Megan and Harry you know the
prince and the princess or whatever she
is and Jennifer Lawrence and Kanye West
we're going to dive into a whole bunch
of all that stuff and then we got some
great questions they're kind of all over
the map today so I'm looking forward to
that uh and before we get to it let me
talk to you guys about bullying Max real
quick you know as in relation surpasses
eyes not seen in 40 years the value of
the dollar is decreasing with every
passing day you're paying more at the
pump the grocery store for cars and for
housing face it paper money is worth
less guys the timing couldn't be any
better for my new sponsor bullion Max
bullion Max is a direct to Consumer
precious metals retailer who can help
you diversify into gold and silver it's
a hedge against inflation it's also
security for your family in times of
Crisis and here's why I love bullion max
they're owned by veterans in the
precious metals space offers some of the
lowest prices on the internet and they
make it so easy to buy directly from
their website I want to help you get
started so I worked out a special offer
just for you get bullion Max's silver
starter kit at employee pricing just go
to booleanmax.com Dave the kit includes
five of the most desirable silver
products to invest in including the
silver American eagle and a silver
Australian kangaroo
this offer is limited to just one per
household so get yours now go to
bullionmax.com Dave and now back to me
all right
so let's talk about Harry and Megan for
just a moment as you know across the
pond in Great Britain in England they
have a monarchy they have a king at
times a king and at times a queen
sometimes both at the same time the
whole situation uh and uh this is
something that they have had for
thousands of years uh well I suppose
well the monarchy is thousands of years
old thousands of years old it's no it's
an old monarchy big building that's the
whole thing they've had it for quite
some time and it lasts it is something
that lasts there's a permanence to it so
you might get a conservative government
and you might get a liberal government
and you might have a Centrist government
in but the monarchy always remains and
that has allowed for a certain set of
consistency in the UK you may not like
that they have all this money and all
this power and influence and by
Birthright that these people hand it
over from generation to generation but
there is something about the idea of
permanence something that the country
can all sort of wrap around that's not
just purely political that I think is
interesting and worthy of exploring well
in some ways it's kind of crumbling
because of wokism so first I want to
show you a headlight from The Babylon B
and I do have to tell you that the
Babylon bee is a satire site I know that
confuses a lot of people on the left
they had a great headline because uh
these two over here they've got this new
Netflix special coming out Harry and
Megan announced Netflix special about
how much they want privacy that is that
is humor via the Babylon B uh but I want
to show you just a little bit this is
just the teaser trailer for Harry and
Megan's new Netflix documentary and and
you'll see why I'm bringing all this up
it's really hard to look back on it now
and go what on Earth happened
and then
everything changed there's a hierarchy
of the family you know there's leaking
but there's also planting of stories
there was a war against Megan to suit
other people's agendas it's about hatred
it's about race it's a dirty game
pain and suffering of women marrying
into this institution this Feeding
Frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I didn't want a history
to repeat itself
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth
okay so I think it's worth whether you
care about the monarchy or not whether
you care about British politics or not
or any of those things is sort of
irrelevant the reason that this is
important is it goes to what I talk
about in almost every episode that
wokism destroys every institution that
it gets into you can feel
that it is going to destroy the monarchy
one way or another because he and she
will turn and call them racists and call
them part of the patriarchy and all of
those things and it's like what would
England look like post-monarchy I I
suspect it would not be nearly as stable
uh as it is right now and that's not to
say that the monarchy uh is above
criticism of course it can be criticized
but the fact that they're going for
their their own Fame they're going you
know they've they've not really
accomplished anything that hasn't been
sort of handed to them and what they are
using with what was handed to them is to
destroy the thing that handed it to them
it's it's quite fascinating uh page six
which is part of the New York Post has
some more interesting little tidbits on
this whole situation A Prince Harry and
Meghan Markle allegedly used a photo in
their new documentary trailer that they
themselves approved to be taken while
suggesting the Press was invading their
privacy the newest teaser for their
highly anticipated Netflix docu-series
showed a photograph craft taking a snap
sorry showed a photographer taking a
snap of Harry Markle and their young son
Archie From a Balcony at Archbishop
Desmond tudu's residence in South Africa
back in 2019 while they were on an
official tour this photographed used by
Netflix and Harry and Megan to suggest
intrusion by the Press is a complete
travesty British royal correspondent
Robert jobson tweeted Monday it was
taken from an accredited pool at
Archbishop tutu's residence in Cape Town
only three people were in the accredited
position h m Harry and Megan agreed the
position I was there jobson then tweeted
a photo of the former Royals introducing
a then baby Archie to the Archbishop
this shot by me from the same accredited
pool position on my iPhone was taken at
Archbishop tutu's Cape Town residence he
wrote alongside the photo there was no
intrusion I was part of a 3 person UK
Palace pool nobody else was allowed in
and we shared the words and photos with
the UK media okay guys I understand that
it's not that important but you see
they're even faking their own lack of
privacy I'm not saying that there are no
privacy issues related to this but it's
just one of these other things where
everything in front of us these days is
this constructed reality they literally
chose a photo that was an approved photo
by the pool of photographers at Desmond
Tutu's house and they made it seem as if
this was something that allowed them
afforded them no privacy whatsoever but
what is this all really about it's
really about how to take out a monarchy
how to take out all of the old things
right how to take out all of the
institutions that have freed people and
from a western perspective that have
focused on individual rights and given
us a sense of history and all of those
things you may remember this this is
Meghan Markle accusing Harry in the the
monarchy of uh well racism duh so we
have in tandem the conversation of you
won't be given security he's not going
to be given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what about how dark your baby is going
to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like oh
it was an accusation of racism about
someone in Harry's family we have since
been told it was not a reference to the
queen nor Prince Philip who were part of
this historic picture with Megan's
mother Doria Ragland and Archie shortly
after he was born that was relayed to me
from Harry those were conversations that
family had with him what was that
conversation
that conversation I am never going to
share my father and my brother they are
trapped
they don't get to leave
and I have huge compassion for that guys
he's so ethical this Harry he's never
gonna share the conversation that they
had about the baby being too dark but
he'll tell it to Megan and then Megan
can tell Oprah and then Oprah can ask
him about it but he's not going to share
any information about that conversation
look I don't know if it's true or not
true but the broader point is they are
using the power that I mean just imagine
to be given all the privilege that they
have been given and use it to destroy
the thing that gave you the privilege
and of course what they don't realize in
their short-sighted woke stupor is that
no matter how much they give to the
woksters No No matter how much they
disassemble the monarchy or pretend to
live in poverty and of course they're
they're going to live like the elites of
the elite of the elites and say all the
right things and call everyone racist
and everyone's always no matter how much
they give they will always be the bad
guys in the eyes of the woke and
I don't know how they don't have someone
around them telling them that there is
no Penance that will be enough you guys
are bad guys you were born rich and
you're white and you have everything and
no matter how much you give away until
you decide to walk around in a in a
potato sack
in you know downtown London or something
like that it will not be good enough but
celebrities in general are not the
wisest people often have a myopic view
of the world often think that everything
revolves around them and that nothing
came before them uh this video is going
viral yesterday this is this is
absolutely incredible so Jennifer
Lawrence Jennifer Lawrence was in Hunger
Games she was uh she was in X-Men who's
the blue girl Mystique she was Mystique
in the the new X-Men movies she's done a
couple other things uh here she is
saying that before her there were no
chicks doing lead acting roles in action
movies I think she may have a limited
memory I remember when I was doing
Hunger Games nobody had ever put a woman
in the lead of an action movie because
it wouldn't work we were told girls and
boys can both identify with a male lead
but boys cannot identify with a female
lead oh absolutely and it just makes me
so happy every single time I see a movie
come out out that just blows through
every single one of those beliefs and
proves
that it is just a lie to keep certain
people out of the movies to keep certain
people in the same positions that
they've always been in and it's just
amazing to watch it happen and watch you
at the helm guys there's been a massive
conspiracy that Jennifer Lawrence has
unfurled she did it Scooby-Doo style she
ripped the mask off before her there
were no lead actors in action movies
it's not as if the internet exists where
you might be able to video
I can handle myself
yeah I noticed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
congrats Jennifer Lawrence you just
erased all of those chicks unless she
knows something we don't know maybe she
knows they all have penises in which
case they're still chicks right isn't
that how this thing works it's also
confusing anyway just such silliness
like this it's the same sort of
um like very narrow view of the world
Meghan Markle comes into the monarchy
and thinks that she knows best about
everything and should disassemble it
Jennifer Lawrence comes into Hollywood
and thinks no one did anything before
her it's this weird thing it's this
weird thing about that has something to
do with people I don't know maybe under
the age of 40 like everything before
them was so horrible and backwards it's
such nonsense nonsense but every now and
again you get a celebrity that gets one
right and uh you know I haven't said too
much about the the Kanye Hitler stuff we
talked about it like a week or two ago
it's also stupid I think we should just
ignore him he's obviously not well he's
surrounded by really horrible people he
has noxious bad ideas hopefully he will
come around and I think the best way to
get people to come around is for
everyone to just kind of live honestly
and forthrightly and then you know the
truth will set you free kind of thing uh
but Bill Burr you guys might know
comedian Bill Burr uh he had an
incredible take on Kanye this is from a
couple years ago and it's been making
the rounds and I just thought this was
absolutely perfect kind of put a button
on the Kanye thing so we can just move
past it okay
Steve Kanye's going off on himself I'm
telling you just close your eyes forget
it's him and really listen to what is
coming out of this guy's mouth
genius
I'm a God I'm Shakespeare
my biggest regret is I'll never get to
see myself perform live
that's a direct quote my biggest regret
is I'll never get to see myself perform
live dude you put that ego in a white
dude that is it benign and it's Thrice
and what's the blitz pink
what's the superior race
Vienna will return to Deutschland first
I mean that's pretty good and that's
from a couple years ago uh to put a
final pin in the Kanye thing and
hopefully he'll just kind of go away for
a while and this story will just kind of
disappear and people will realize just
because someone says all kinds of crazy
things we don't have to focus on it all
day that's why I wasn't doing video
after video about it I saw this video
this is from probably about 30 years ago
this is Thomas Seoul uh talking about
anti-Semitism I thought it was pretty
pretty pretty good it's a fascinating
story because among the the middleman
minorities of which the Jews are the
most prominent uh the hostility of these
people in countries around the world is
out of all proportion of that so any
other kind of group I can think of
uh in terms of violence the number of uh
of uh block the number of Chinese kill
let's say in one year
uh and by mob actually exceeds all the
blacks lynched in the entire history of
the United States
and the number of Armenians killed in uh
in Turkey you know during the first
world war is greater than that of course
the number of Jews slaughtered on a
number of occasions in history even
before the Holocaust is greater than
that
so that the question is why this
particular kind of people are the
targets of so much uh us venomous hatred
and I think the answer is that
um based days not only succeed they
succeed in a way which is the threat to
the egos of other people but the guy who
comes here let's say from Vietnam or
Korea and arrives here with little more
than the clothes in his back and a few
word broken words of broken English uh
and a decade later he has his own little
business and you see his son a few years
after that getting ready to go off to
Harvard or MIT you got to ask yourself
you've either gotta you know you you've
got to hate yourself for saying my god
I've been stagnating this guy was
nothing and now he's whizzing up or
you're gonna have to hate him years ago
when uh official of one of the Jewish
organizations in New York asked me what
can Jews themselves do uh in order to
minimize the hostility they face I gave
him a one-word answer fail
because as long as you succeed you're
going to be hated
as long as you succeed you're going to
be hated
but clearly as Thomas Saul knows it's
better to succeed and be hated than to
fail and be loved and that is right
there the inherent problem with wokeness
if you believe that victimhood that
whatever is wrong with you or whatever
historical Injustice happened to people
who look like you or sound like you if
you think that that is what gives you
worth you will never give up whoa we
gotta we got a situation behind me we've
got a situation what's going on please
stand by all right we're going to fix
that in just a sec sorry about that guys
uh but I'll the audio's still going
right we're still going on audio yeah as
you know if you believe that that
victimhood is the most important thing
you will never give up that victimhood
that's as simple as it gets and what
he's saying is hey here's a bunch of
people who came here with nothing worked
real hard cared about family cared about
education etc etc and they have
actually succeeded and that is why they
are hated and by the way there is a
moment in one of the Kanye rants uh from
about two weeks ago where he kept saying
I'm jealous I'm jealous of them I'm
jealous of them
pretty sure the jealousy is something
like a sin somebody said that somewhere
right I think that happened somewhere
um
so I think you get the point uh Thomas
Soul whether it's Thomas Seoul in uh
2022 or it's Thomas Seoul you know good
35 40 years ago he always he always just
absolutely Nails it guys just bear with
us on this uh little technical
difficulty here sorry about that we'll
we'll get that going in just a second uh
we're good yeah all right we're gonna
we're gonna roll into the ad and then I
think we'll be able to solve this little
problem apologies uh guys this holiday
season I want to give a gift to my loved
ones that makes them feel special and
unique just like the relationship we
share that's why I'm giving everyone I
care about story worth story worth is an
online service that helps you and your
loved ones preserve precious memories
and stories for years to come it's a
thoughtful and meaningful gift that
connects connects you to those who
matter most every week story worth
emails your relative or friend a
thought-provoking question of your
choice from their vast pool of possible
options each unique prompt asks
questions you've never thought of
thought to ask like what's the brave
thing you've ever done in your life or
if you could see into the future what
would you want to find out after one
year story worth Will compile all your
loved ones stories including photos into
a beautiful Keepsake book that you'll be
able to share and revisit for
generations to come I'm going to give my
keepsake book to my two baby boys when
they're older and they're grown up fast
reading the weekly stories helps connect
you with loved ones no matter how near
or far apart you are with story worth
I'm giving those I love a most
thoughtful personal gift from the heart
and preserving their memories and
stories for years to come go to
storyworth.com Reuben and save ten
dollars on your first purchase that's
storyworth.com Reuben to save ten
dollars on your first purchase all right
we got a
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q and
A and away we go Margaret says literally
the same people who thought they could
get away with the trump-russia collusion
narrative orchestrated the hunter by in
laptop cover-up they have been found out
on both but not after dire consequences
what can be done to deter the Deep
State's nefarious actions in the future
you know I've been thinking a lot about
this because
the more stuff we find out so if we find
out okay or we have in essence already
found out that Russia collusion was a
hoax right we found it out the
intelligence Services lied steel dossier
all of those things so we know they lied
about that now we find out that the
hunter Biden laptop was totally legit
most of us knew it or or were at least
roughly aware of it or at least kind of
looking in that direction that it was
probably sort of true because the whole
system was trying to silence it so it
was like yeah there's probably something
there now we find out that it's all true
mainstream media was all calling it a
hoax and a lie and all of the 51 you
know intelligence agencies who all uh
representatives of the intelligence
agencies who all said it was nonsense we
will find out more stuff related to all
this we will find out as I said
yesterday we're going to find out that
they were doing all sorts of crazy stuff
when it comes to censorship related to
covid I mean I think the covid stuff is
going to make the hunter Biden laptop
stuff look like absolutely nothing like
when we really unfurl that if you really
like just think back for a moment to how
crazy the last two and a half years have
been and all of you know when like in LA
when they're literally closing the skate
park and they're taking basketball hoops
down and just like all of the craziness
and that there were some people like hey
maybe we should pause maybe we shouldn't
Force vaccines like okay you guys get
all the stuff so they're gonna just do
more and more your question though
really is what can be done like does
anything change did the bad guys ever
pay for it
um
not to be too black filled here but they
don't often pay for it right we don't
have a lot of great evidence of when
people do really bad things in the
government uh that or when they come
after you in in horrible ways that they
pay for it right and then it's not just
that you could look at this FTX thing
and it's like billions and billions of
dollars are lost and unaccounted for and
in essence stolen from people and it's
like it feels like this kid's gonna get
off this sandbagment freed it feels like
he's gonna get off you know people that
are in the system itself becomes a
protection racket for the system that's
why it's so appealing for so many people
to be part of the system because you
feel like you're in the mafia you're
gonna get protection you know and there
there is some value in that if your
ultimate goal is just to survive right I
suppose without your integrity it's not
really my ultimate goal but I can
understand how someone could come to
that conclusion that's just that's just
a real thing so I don't know that much
will change the best we can do which
which is what I try to do on this show
every single day is show people that
truth is out there and that you don't
have to follow the narrative and
that just because the system tells you
something it doesn't mean it's true and
how do you how do you become more
reliant on yourself and your family and
your local community so that all the
nonsense that they're always pushing on
us doesn't matter that much I think
that's really what you can do Eliza says
I just watched your 7 out of ten threes
actually Elisa it was it was eight out
of ten but all right so are you showing
us that if we want to be better at
basketball we should first test positive
for covid yes that's what the scientists
told me if you're an average basketball
player and you get coveted you will
suddenly be a better basketball player
that's how it works that is absolutely
how it works I should tell you guys in
total transparency that was a two-take
situation I walked out of the studio
yesterday Phoenix came with me we walked
out there shot it once I think I hit
four out of ten first time I'm just
being honest but eight out of ten the
second time so if you take that that's
uh you know that's 12 out of 20. still
over half have fun threes that's pretty
solid uh Veronica says how much has your
time on Twitter gone up since since Elon
Musk acquired it who is someone you rely
on and follow for honest journalism
you know it's interesting I know I talk
about Twitter a lot here and I think
even for those of you that are not on
Twitter you get why so many of us talk
about it why the The Taste makers are on
there because all of it all the stuff
all the pr all the cultural
the Gestalt all the stuff it's all
happening right there on Twitter and
that's where it's being disseminated so
you can either be on there or not be on
there but it's still an important piece
of what's going on in our I don't like
the word Collective but what's going on
in our Collective mind right our hive
mind
um I guess I'm on a little bit more
since he's been back on because well
first off because since they've lifted
the shadow bands and since I'm actually
seeing a feed of people I follow again
it seems fun again or at least it seems
somewhat interesting again versus before
where it was highly highly regulated and
my tweets started getting virtually no
traction I used to be able to tweet a
picture of a banana and a cup of coffee
and I could get 10 000 retweets then
they they had really just crushed me
down to like you know 20 retweets on
things everyone kept messaging me I've
never seen your stuff that now it seems
to have gotten normal there's a bit of a
catch-22 here because for me I think I
said on the show about two months ago
maybe it was right when I came back on
the grid
that my goal was to be off Twitter by
the end of the year and I really did
mean it and what I meant by that at the
time it was before Elon got it there
were obviously the rumors that he was
going to get it but that it felt like it
was falling apart Jordan Peterson had
left like I felt that there was like a
pathway to an exit meaning that you know
I'm of a certain level of online
popularity or whatever it is like do I
need it much more now that he's come
back and it's the center of the universe
related to all of the things that we
talk about with politics and culture and
much more I mean plenty of people use
Twitter for Just Sports or when you
people use Twitter for music or whatever
um I have to be there and it has become
fun again that being said the locals
Community is a million times better in
terms of actual communication with real
people and sharing pictures of food and
dogs and what you're listening to and
what you're watching and that's where I
actually interact with people so to me
the locals Community uh is that's my
home online and Twitter Twitter is the
Town Square those are two separate
things and I treat them separately
Douglas says I just wanted to ask since
you're filling the jar to get someone
out of a red State and into a blue state
or out of a blue State and into a red
State can you give that money to someone
who lives in a blue State and moves into
a red State hint hint yes okay so you
know I've been putting all the money
over the over the year into the jar here
there's there's more than that we've
emptied the jar a couple times and I'm
going to throw in a couple thousand
bucks at the end of the a year we are
going to give someone a bunch of money
to leave California
and move to Florida we had I had
temporarily reversed it I thought we
could just fund a Democrat or a lefty
leaving Florida but after this 20-point
win by DeSantis it's like ah let the few
of them stay here it's fine okay you're
not bothering anybody although I would I
guess maybe for Charlie Crist but it's
again it's like he's this like impotent
irrelevant nothing so it doesn't matter
so yes it will be for someone to get out
of Cali because I think that's the most
important thing and that's that would be
modeling after me leaving California
which was almost a year ago it's just
under a year December 17th will be my
one year anniversary here in Florida
um so we will figure it out it will be
someone from the locals Community I know
a few of you have already posted with
your own stories of why you are
deserving and we will pick somebody in
the next couple weeks Elizabeth says hi
Dave question do you think there's a
connection between Joe Biden and
zelenski resulting in all of this usaid
pouring over to Ukraine yeah like
there's something there and that's
obviously connected to the laptop the
issue with the laptop was not just that
okay he was smoking crack on a webcam
and banging hookers everybody likes a
good time it was not that the issue with
the laptop was that there were emails
and his text messages that were
obviously synced to his phone and all of
that stuff about his business dealings
and that's the stuff that they were
really trying to hide clearly I don't
think they were thrilled with the with
the nudity or whatever that stuff was
right like obviously not and if he had
been doing illegal things like they
don't he's the son of the president of
the United States they don't want that
getting out there fine but that really
wasn't what this was about right because
this was we've got to silence this
laptop before the election because we
clearly feel there is something on here
that could tank Biden and that's exactly
what they did we also know that Joe
Biden who repeatedly has said he has
never discussed his son's business
dealings with his son think how crazy
that is think how crazy that is for any
of you out there that have a father or
that are a son do you not discuss what
you do with your father
if you have a relationship with your
father obviously you do do he so you're
telling me what Joe Biden is telling us
this is what he's telling us his son got
a job at barisma this is a Ukrainian
Energy company he had no business he's
making tons and tons of money hundreds
of thousands of dollars there he had no
business there he only got the job
because of who his dad was and you're
saying that his dad never said to him
son what are you doing for a living oh
how's that job at Prisma going boy
you're working at a Ukraine Energy
company that's kind of funny because I
thought you were a crack addict like is
there any level of reality with any of
this stuff so I think there is something
there I also think that that generally
speaking the Ukraine situation strikes
me as just a giant money laundering
operation that is not a defense of
Russia every country has Sovereign
borders you can't bust into somebody
else's country I get that there's it's a
little more complex there because they
were a former uh Soviet satellite and
you know some of the people in Crimea
want to be Russians okay fine
but we have to you know Borders or
borders uh that's just how it is and it
seems to me that as we checked yesterday
we've given about 20 billion dollars to
Ukraine we have no receipts on this
stuff we don't know where it's going we
don't know if it's going to good guys or
bad guys and at the same freaking time
the Biden Administration is canceling
FEMA Aid to the people in Southwest
Florida who need it who need you know it
was something like 25 million bucks so
of course DeSantis comes in with State
funds and makes up for it but we can't
find 25 million bucks through FEMA to
help our own citizens here but we can
find 20 billion that's a lot of zeros
billion for Ukraine something's rotten
in stink town uh Freedom says hey Dave
your covid hoop therapy was epic are you
looking forward to teaching your boys
about playing sports yeah I can't wait
to play basketball with them uh which is
why I've been getting PRP in my knee
that's they take your blood out they
spin it in the centrifuge they like
inject the good stuff back in your knee
because I got this torn ACL and I want
to be able to run around with these kids
and play catch and so mostly basketball
but I'll do the baseball thing with them
too I don't like soccer
I find it boring not that interested but
I know all kids always start at soccer
right it's just that's the easiest one
to start at we're gonna have to try to
shift them out of that but there's a lot
of soccer down here in Florida but
there's a lot of baseball too so we're
gonna we're gonna make a work there's a
lot of tennis but yeah I am looking
forward to getting out there and playing
with them we're not quite there yet
although
big news do we have a breaking news sign
or something do we we don't have
something uh Justin rolled over for the
first time last night
I was not in the room because of the
coveted situation I had to watch from
outside but uh flipped over did not flip
back one thing at a time you know Grace
says good to have you back uh when you
were speaking at the Republican Congress
did they seem able to work with some
cohesiveness do you think they will be
able to get anything done in the next
two years so just to clarify what she's
talking about I spoke on Monday in DC uh
to the new Congressional Republicans
just sort of about messaging and about
social media and how to leverage the
digital platforms and more broadly on
where you can focus your energies maybe
a little bit less on mainstream media
who are never going to give you a share
a fair shake and maybe a little bit more
on you know some of these online
platforms that was the the basic Genesis
of what I was talking about I I was
pretty impressed with a bunch of the
people I spoke to a few of them after I
think the real All-Star in the new
Republican Congress and it's not just
because I had her on the show but
Harriet Hageman uh I think you know
who's the one that replaced Liz Cheney
and won I think by about 40 points if
I'm not mistaken I mean she won in a
massive Landslide now it's a tiny little
District they only have one Congress
person okay fine but she she strikes me
as someone that's really serious that's
an absolute professional she was a if
I'm not mistaken she was an energy
sector lawyer before this she knows her
stuff she cares she seems she seems
pretty Fearless to me I think she's got
a really bright future ahead of her but
for the most part
what I really was pushing on them was
that the media will never treat you
fairly so I said if you go and do
mainstream media if you go to the view
if you go to MSNBC or CNN
bring receipts I literally said do what
Ted Cruz did right remember that day Ted
Cruz we showed it to you a couple weeks
ago on The View when he's talking about
election interference and he busts out
the paper and you've got wait a minute
wait a minute you guys say Trump's the
only one who denied an election Hillary
Clinton Stacy Abrams
etc etc right there like bring receipts
so you can get those viral Clips that's
what you got to do and more than
anything else I I told them you know
model what's going on here in Florida
Pick Your fights well do what DeSantis
is doing be clear and clean and and
fight the media when it's appropriate
but just do the job I think people just
want competency now more than anything
we have been surrounded by a bunch of
clownish buffoons for long enough it's
time to just have some decency
uh Julie says hello Dave glad you're
feeling well enough to be on the show
today thank you Julie have you ever
questioned the covid test I've heard
that the test doesn't actually test for
the virus despite the entire world
population using the PCR test yeah look
as I mentioned at the top I only took
the test because of the boys I had I
come home and had a little scratch in my
throat and it was just the two of us I
would not have done it I was just doing
what you know I was taking the maximum
amount of precaution related to having
two newborns here that's that do I think
the tests are perfect absolutely not is
it ridiculous that the United States
government which sent all of us remember
Joe Biden in his State of the Union I'm
going to send you all to kova tests look
at me that's great uh yeah they sent us
all covet tests and you're not going to
believe where the government covid tests
are from can you can you guess come on
Connor I'll give you one what he's good
China yeah made in China that's where we
get our covid tests from and guess what
covet also made in China I've enjoyed
being on YouTube goodbye everybody
um
I don't know if they're truthful or not
truthful and and that gets to my point
earlier about the testing it's like sort
of what is the point sort of was the
point I come home I have this little
twang in my throat okay I'm out there
all day yesterday running around doing
cardio playing basketball I feel fine
today I gave my guys a choice as to
whether they wanted to come into work
just just to do the right thing right
and they both made decisions that were
right for them and if one of them had
said we're not going to do it then they
wouldn't have done it and we would have
been okay
um and that's the way we should have
treated this thing from the beginning
instead of destroying the known Society
uh perhaps we could have been a little
more mature about it but that's also why
I always show you guys some old clips
about what happened fauci from two years
ago Biden from two years ago because we
have to remember how they did this to us
because I guarantee they're gonna do it
again a lot of people have coveted in
New York right now Kathy hochel who
locked everybody down and told people to
get out of New York if you don't have
her values she's in charge still so of
course they'll figure out a way to lock
people down again or force them to do
this or that or the other thing of
course they'll do it La wants to bring
back mask mandates right now it's like
go for it that's what you guys want and
I know it sucks if you're a good decent
person in LA and there's at least two of
them that I know still no I know three
guys we got Dennis Prager we got the
Adam Carolla we got the Larry Elder you
guys know anyone else good in L.A
that's it there's the big three and
their wives
that's it but if you guys that's what
you want in La then have had it and we
will just live in very very different
worlds and in this world we'll be
outside and enjoying ourselves uh Chris
says we know you and David both love to
cook the cast iron chicken parm is
legendary yes that's right but what is
your favorite meal or dish to prepare
for someone PS a few months ago someone
asked in an AMA about getting good pizza
in Miami Crust Pizza downtown is a
must-have though hardly New York style
Crust Pizza downtown we don't get
downtown that often but I will keep that
in mind I would also recommend uh it's
fancy Pizza it's not a New York style
pizza but Mr o1 here in uh in Miami
there's a couple locations they have a
pizza it sounds nuts it's got coffee
grinds and hot honey
it's unfreaking believable I know coffee
pizza sounds bananas but trust me it's
great uh the first question what do I
like to cook for people well because of
the smoker I mean I love that big green
egg smoker so when we've had you know
obviously we've had a lot of family here
over the last two months or so I love
getting a whole filet mignon I'm talking
about the whole tenderloin so that could
be you know that could be a good four
and a half pounds like it's a serious
freaking piece of meat uh salt and
pepper and then you just smoke that
thing and the thing is with the
tenderloin the whole idea is it's tender
already you know when you're smoking
things you're doing it slowly because
the slower you do it like brisket
brisket is a very very tough piece of
meat I'm giving I'm doing meat 101 today
so the reason brisket is cheap is
because it's not something that you can
just throw on the grill and eat just
like that right so it's cheap because it
takes a long time to cook so that's why
if you go to Texas you go to a great you
know barbecue joint it's like they've
often cooked that stuff overnight 14
hours something like that so I've done a
couple of briskets where we've gone 810
hours but with the filet mignon it's
already super tender so you can cook a
filet mignon in a smoker I'm talking a
whole filet mignon like that you could
cook it in basically an hour and then I
like to caveman it after which is so
this is a reverse sear you're cooking it
on indirect heat because when you're
smoking basically you put a plate under
it the heat the fire is coming up it's
hitting the plate now only it's only
being cooked by smoke right but what you
don't have at that point at the end you
don't have that beautiful Char so then
you take the plate out you get that
flame freaking going I'm talking
explosive nuclear flame and then you
just throw that piece of meat down there
and you look at it and you think about
it and you do that for about a minute
and a half and you flip it you put a
glove on you get your hand in the fire
you flip it there's a lord of the
ringers thing here somewhere right
something about a guy with a hand and a
fire you flip it you do that
do a little butter on top a little a
little garlic oil something like that
and just the salt and pepper Mamma Mia
davidscookbook.com if you want some more
of the recipes of the things reading
unfortunately he hasn't updated it
lately two kids getting a little it's a
little tough around here but yes the
chicken the cast iron chicken parm is an
absolute favorite that's the one that
when our
friends come over that's what everyone's
always requesting because there's
nothing better than a good chicken parm
Megan Kelly said it was the best chicken
parm she's ever had and I'm told she's
eating a lot of chicken parm up today
over the years Michael says I'm a
Christian conservative and decided to
support your channel as a way of giving
during the holiday season to people I
watch a lot on YouTube well thank you
you're a man who speaks truth to power
and I appreciate that no matter what God
you pray to I wanted to ask if you're
thinking about teaching your kids the
Bible or Torah uh well first off the
Bible says sure
um well first off thank you for being
here and one of the things that I love
about the community the locals Community
but really everywhere that any of you
listen to me we have a really diverse
set of people that watch this show I can
tell you guys that having been on tour
last spring and bouncing around you know
we literally went from coast to coast
and everywhere in between
um you know when I would do certain
jokes on stage uh or talk about certain
topics like if you were to say to me hey
Dave is your audience pro-life or
pro-choice now I think most of my
audience is pro-life
um you guys know my feeling like 15
weeks which is what we have in here in
Florida now they're going to be but yet
people still came to see me we have some
different political views we might have
some different personal views or
certainly different lifestyle views
right
views on all sorts of different things
but that's the beautiful thing and
that's what America was and that's what
America really sort of got to we got to
the Pinnacle of that I would say as
someone that was a child of the 80s and
the 90s and then grew up in the 2000s it
was like we had put so much of this
stuff to bed that yeah okay so what you
have some differences opinions with
people big big damn whoop so I'm very
proud that we've built an audience here
that I think really is respectful of
those things even if you look in the the
YouTube comment section or or most of
the whatever whatever you're viewing
it's like our comment sections are
pretty decent it's not to say there's no
trolls or mean people of course there
are but it's like we've got people
thinking about things I think in the
right way so now to directly answer your
question about uh about the Bible and
the Torah
um yes for sure you know I am I am well
it's certainly the word I am absolutely
blessed to have people like Dennis
Prager and Jordan Peterson in my life
and I already spoke to the two of them
you may remember about a week before
Justin was born I had Jordan and Dennis
over for dinner and I just wanted to
have like a I don't know this is sort of
a final
I'm about to be a parent conversation
with the two guys that I think have sort
of affected me intellectually and and
spiritually and philosophically the most
and how incredible that I get a chance
to do that with Jordan Peterson and
Dennis Prager right and
um and we did talk a little bit about
that like how are we not only going to
try to teach them the right things from
a you know a sort of secular perspective
but also incorporate uh history and
family and religion and all of those
things Dennis certainly uh because he
happens to be Jewish obviously can lead
me in a certain way on that Jordan's
series by the way on on Exodus and the
Old Testament which is on daily wire
plus right now I've been watching it it
is phenomenal it is phenomenal oh and by
the way Jordan also
you know I interviewed Bibi Netanyahu
the Prime Minister the twice and future
Prime Minister of Israel uh which part
two is up right now and the full things
on locals already Jordan also did an
hour and a half sit down with him which
I watched while doing cardio yesterday
it's phenomenal absolutely phenomenal so
uh yeah we're we're gonna figure out
ways to have a community and and do some
things and my sister and her three kids
her husband and three kids live down
here and we'll do some uh Shabbat
dinners and
try to pave away to a sane future
Rory says what the hell is going on with
the Arizona governor's race we can't
even get information and we live here
yeah look I don't even know that I've
said basically anything about it since
like a day or two after they announced
that Katie Hobbs won something doesn't
seem right there but they're just not
going to reverse this thing I I hate to
tell you like I think Kyrie lake is
probably fighting a somewhat just fight
I do you guys know I supported her and I
like her
um I think Katie Hobbs is just kind of
the worst nothingness left this Democrat
and the fact that she is is the one
that's in charge of the election process
while also being someone that's running
is is crazy but it's not going to get
reversed it's not going to get reversed
and I hopefully this is part of the
problem it's it's not even it's not even
did something wrong or nefarious happen
it's that so many people now believe
that the
um the inconclusiveness is built into
the system that over time that degrades
their their ability to believe into this
to believe the system right that's
Loosely to quote Padme Amidala from
Revenge of the Sith it's like when we
stop believing democracy works that's
when it stops working was that Padme or
the other I think it was the other it
was the queen that took over after Padme
over there on Naboo Queen what's her
name who's the queen that took over for
Padme and Naboo oh Phoenix is not happy
with this one he's like look man I'll
look up how many people were shot in
Chicago but I'm not looking up
it doesn't matter it was the queen who
took over for Padme after she left and
she became the senator she said if you
the moment we stop believing in
democracy is the moment that we lose it
and that's kind of right it's like the
more that we all think that elections
don't work the further we get away from
a functioning system and I sort of do
think that that is kind of uh baked in
right now her name thank you Phoenix I
appreciate it I know that was pushing
the limits the queen that replaced Queen
Amidala when she became senator of Naboo
instead of queen of Naboo what's going
on back here her name
was Queen Jamila we're having some tech
stuff today guys I apologize for that
we're gonna we're gonna look into this
and figure it out I'm gonna keep rolling
though for here for a sec Phoenix work
with me on the uh prompter here Bernardo
says I saw on Twitter how both you and
Francis Suarez are lobbying to try to
get Elon Musk to move Twitter to Miami
any chance you can reach out to Ron
DeSantis to help seeing that Elon has
expressed support for him it would be a
huge win for Florida so yeah there is uh
there's a couple you know because these
hit pieces are just coming out day after
day on Elon and obviously San Francisco
as a city and California as a state
these are not friendlies to a guy like
Elon Musk right there are not places
that are going to do the best so that he
can hire the best people and the type of
people that want to live in San
Francisco at this point are probably not
the type of people that he wants to work
for him as a matter of fact he just
fired you know something like half the
company and oddly the product seems to
be working better than ever
um so
because of all these hit pieces and then
there was a there was a piece written
about how San Francisco was going to
look into Twitter because he got rid of
beds that were in the office I guess
they used to let employees sleep there
and he didn't want them to sleep there
anymore so he got rid of beds so now the
mayor was going to look into him uh so I
I retweeted something and I just said
you know get your ass down to Miami man
I bet Francis Suarez the mayor of Miami
can help and as you guys know I mean
Francis Suarez down here he's basically
turned Miami into the tech Hub of the
future this is the this is the city of
the future and it is thriving and doing
unbelievably well and you know there are
sort their attacks well there's
generally low taxes here then there are
tax breaks if you bring your company
here I think they help you find office
space and and I'm sure there's a Litany
of other things that Suarez could help
with on the DeSantis front
um if I see any movement that elon's
really thinking about it I would see if
I could do anything on that front
obviously I can contact people at the uh
from the DeSantis Administration and see
about it uh you know some people did of
course comment you know Dave are you
sure you would want a company like
Twitter to move here because then it
moves all the lobsters here this is a
case where well actually I think he's
gotten rid of most of the walksters so I
think it would be safe and then he would
get a much better pool of talent you
know what I mean we don't have a hard
time uh by any estimation hiring people
here because good people want to live
here and work here and build families
and a life here oh and speaking of all
of that I want to give a shout out to
our new social media guy our new
graphics guy our guy that's pretty much
doing a little bit of everything behind
the scenes Brock we just hired him
started this week absolute All-Star and
you're going to see all sorts of new fun
viral stuff and a bunch more and maybe
he's going to move to Miami so let's see
what we can do about that let's let's
see what we can do Kelly says Dave what
is your and David's favorite Christmas
movie our family adopted the ref as ours
of course it got uh one uh of course it
was once our children got older right
because it's a little bit of an older
Christmas Time movie David's absolute
favorite by far is Christmas Story you
know they show it on TNT 24 hours a day
on Christmas Day we don't have cable
anymore
so I think we bought it on Apple TV or
something and he likes that playing
throughout the day and just cooking and
relaxing and enjoying whatever family is
over for me it's Christmas vacation I
just think it's like Chevy Chase just
absolutely at his best uh just absolute
perfection but and I know this is
controversial I do consider Die Hard a
Christmas movie you
you accept it you oh we all do wow what
about you watching at home if you accept
die hard as a Christmas I mean it's got
Christmas music it happens at a
Christmas party nakatomi Tower the whole
thing you know what I mean Jeff says
what are your thoughts on the Warnock
versus Walker results did this put an
end to Trump's campaign uh you know I
didn't even mention it yesterday it was
funny
we had such a jam-packed show yesterday
and because of the covid thing and
everything else we do the entire run
through then I do the entire show and
then the second the show ended I turned
to Phoenix and I was like wait a minute
did uh I take it walk or lost right like
I wasn't even fully sure about what
happened because it just it just kind of
petered out at the end I'm not surprised
it's why I didn't do much last week on
the race like unfortunately it was kind
of just headed this way and you could
feel it and it is what it is and you
know having the fact that camp who won
big over Stacey Abrams wasn't on the
ticket this time obviously was going to
hurt Walker this time around and the
Democrats have all this early voting and
all the ballot harvesting and all the
stuff okay fine
uh so what are my thoughts well look
Warnock is a bad dude he is uh I think
he is a racist he is a modern
Progressive woke racist I think he's got
the wrong ideas related to basically
everything I don't think he's proud to
be an American and I think he will usher
in more nonsense that's that Herschel
Walker really really did try I hope he
maintains some level of public life and
I have a feeling he'll do good things in
his career or whatever that ends up
being did this put an end to Trump's
campaign I mean I don't think so but
it's not good for Trump it's certainly
not good for well it's not good for the
Republicans and it's not good for Trump
you know Trump still has to figure out
what is it that he wants to do here if
his main driving point is to run because
of election fraud which is mostly what
he's talking about on Truth social you
know he puts up these posts that then
make their way around
I don't know that that's a winning
ticket I just don't know that it is
um I think there's a winning ticket that
has a little more to do with competency
and track record and all of those things
um so you know he also announced very
very early like the momentum let's say
there was momentum two weeks ago when he
announced it's like it kind of feels
like an afterthought right now you got
to now sustain that for the next two
years but I will say this you never
count Trump out you never know what
cards he has up his sleeve and if one
thing if Trump has been proven on one
thing over and over again it's like when
people think he's wrong about something
he ends up being right so do not count
Trump out if DeSantis happens to get in
and they have to battle it out as I've
said I don't think that's a bad thing to
happen publicly we played a video a
couple weeks ago of Jordan Peterson on
Piers Morgan saying maybe that's the
best thing that could happen that they
really have it out and people make a
choice what I would hope is
and this is where it's just going to be
tougher for Trump than it will be for
DeSantis is you can't really get to
Santa's on policy right especially if
you're a republican what could you
possibly he kept the states open he kept
low taxes he did an incredible rebuild
after a crazy hurricane he won by a
landslide he's fighting the woke he's
getting the gender stuff out of schools
like there's nothing you can get him on
on policy if Trump wants to go the other
route which is just pure personal
destruction I guess he can do that but I
don't know that that's the winning
ticket either because I don't think
people are into it anymore and I don't
think people will take too kindly to him
trying to do that to Ron DeSantis who in
essence is America's governor but there
might be some value in them having it
out in that fashion but again we don't
even know if the census is going to run
and it's super early and all that stuff
guys if you have not subscribed join us
at rumble.com Ruben report and as always
if you want to submit questions during
these q and A's and get some of the
personal stuff and the rest of it and AD
free all the videos and everything else
reubenreport.locals.com part two of my
interview with Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu is up on YouTube and
Rumble right now full things up on uh on
locals and uh we leave you this was just
an oldie but a goodie oh but it's three
years ago today right
this is a one of Joe Biden's Greatest
Hits three years ago today see you
tomorrow
man that's true and no one has ever said
that
you see it on the TV now I know you do
and by the way that's why I'm not
sitting there I don't like it up and and
let him go let him go [ __ ] the reason
I'm running is because I've been around
a long time and I know more than most
people know and I can get things done
that's why I'm running and you want to
check my shape on let's do push-ups
together man Let's do let's run let's do
whatever you want to do today
[Applause]
no one has said my son has done anything
wrong and I did not on any occasion and
no one has ever said it not once or
doing anything wrong you said I set up
my son to work in an oil company isn't
that what you said I got your word
straight Jack that's what I hear on that
on MSNBC you don't hear that in MSNBC
you did not hear that at all what you
heard sure okay I'm not gonna
well yeah you do but uh
what the [ __ ] fat what here's a deal
here's the deal